hundreds of people gathered in tulsa
oklahoma last night to mark the 100th
anniversary
of the 1921 massacre that killed and
injured
hundreds of people devastated that
city's black community
and then was hushed up for decades
president biden will travel to tulsa
later today
he's expected to unveil a series of
initiatives
to help communities of color throughout
the u.s omar villafranca
is in tulsa omar good morning
good morning i'm standing in front of
the greenwood cultural center in the
area that's called black wall street
and president biden will visit here and
he'll be the first president to come
here and remember
the victims of the tulsa race massacre
he's going to meet with some of the
survivors
at the cultural center behind me but
he's also expected to talk about some
new policies
the president is expected to announce
actions such as using
federal purchasing power to contract
with small disadvantaged businesses
and new fair housing rules to combat
racial inequality
and also a 10 billion dollar community
revitalization fund
aimed at supporting underdeveloped
communities like those
here in greenwood now the administration
says those efforts will help communities
of color
but people here in tulsa say they've
already lost so much even though the
massacre happened
100 years ago listen to what viola
fletcher had to say she's 107.
listen to her conversation with gail on
our tulsa race massacre special last
night
good education and a nice home and
and a quiet neighborhood and family
that all of that was taken there's so
many things you know that
that i'm still living without now
and she says she is still afraid after
what she witnessed 100 years ago
now earlier she actually went and
testified before congress
talking about reparations for the
community here but it's worth noting
that president biden
is not expected to address reparations
today
gail yeah she was six years old at the
time she's told me that she thinks about
it every single day imagine that and
she's now 107.
thank you omar